c'est surprenant ne va pas d'un citoyen
peut avoir des positions personnelles là
dessus mais c'est pas surprenant pour
l'historien de l'anarchisme que je suis
puisque dans les anarchies ce nouveau
mais tu as il n'y a pas un mouvement
unique se compteraient de ses qualités
sa mouvement pluriel extrêmement
hétérogène avec un tas de tendance il ya
toujours eu des tendances qui qu'on
appelle will légaliste propagandistes
par le fait ou terroristes à des
pandémies terme qui ont coexisté elles
sont largement minoritaires par rapport
à l'ensemble du mouvement libertaire qui
se caractérise soit par le non violence
dans l'héritage de gandhi tolstoï flou
pour les états unis qui a été très
important dans l'arc au syndicalisme en
france la cgt est d'origine alors que
syndicaliste qui était très forte dans
ce qu'on appelle le communisme narjiss
les propositions de communes libres et
indépendantes
il ya tout un ensemble de mouvance qui
disent qu'ils sont largement
majoritaires mais il ya toujours eu
quand même c'est cette tendance à
l'usagé de la violence alors à des fins
différentes
il faut être clair là-dessus le
terrorisme soit il avait une fonction
des fonds s'ils qui peut très bien se
comprendre ceux validés se justifier
dans les périodes de dictature de
conflits de classe serait très très dur
je pense à l'espagne des années 20 to
face à un patronat qui utilisent et les
milices les anarchistes espagnols
avaient monté les contres milices
ouvrières qui faisaient le coup de feu
aussi donc ça peut justifier les
périodes de guerre civile contre le
fascisme espagnol contre les fascistes
dans l'ensemble des pays sud-américains
ne découpe anarchiste qui se sont
révélés qui faisait de la de légalisme
tous crins donc ça ça justifie l'aspect
défensif et revendiquée par la majorité
des anarchistes
ce qui récuse ces usages
trop généralisée de la violence qui peut
déborder parce que la violence est un
acte autoritaire et l'anarchisme et
antiautoritaires par définition de nokia
il ya un hiatus force est là dessus le
deuxième axe de la de vie légalisme
c'est la récupération des moyens pour la
cause
on n'a pas le moyen peut pas éviter et
on ne peut pas faire de journaux il faut
du fric
donc il ya beaucoup d'actions illégales
contre les banques par exemple pour
récupérer des fonds
c'est propre à tous les mouvements
sociale esri aussi de l'histoire
staline par exemple dans une autre
versant l'état et spécialiste de ces
coups de force pour le rappeler mais les
anarchistes ont joué là dessus donc ça
c'était plus ou moins nuit pour la par
l'ensemble des mouvements parce que
rapportait des moyens la fosse poney
également des choses comme ça quoi
il ya une autre tendance galice mkii et
celles liées au mouvement ouvrier qui
s'en prend à des patronats trop trop
vorace et donc mis en place dès
résistance ouvrière on casse les
machines c'est le ludisme fait du
sabotage et donc on essaye de contrôler
un peu cet autoritarisme patronale mais
là on n'est pas du tout la nar mais non
là n'est pas là dedans là il ya la
dernière mouvance qu'est ce que
j'appellerais illégalismes symbolique où
les légalisme psychologique
on essaye dans des actions d'éclat de
montrer que nul n'est à l'abri de
des mises en cause küttel violente cette
fois ci est donc au sens prend soin aux
édifices donc aux édifices publics soit
dans les cas particuliers où s'en prend
à des individus qui ont été juge et
qu'on connaît des compagnons qui ont été
patron et qui ont viré des gens dont on
peut s'en prendre à des voitures on peut
sans point d'un des bâtiments
on peut s'en prendre à des biens
personnels dans la majorité des cas il
faut reconnaître que là c'est condamner
pour le pour l'ensemble du mouvement
parce que on ne s'en prend pas aux gens
nous surprend pas aux biens propres
si on promeut la liberté individuelle
on voit petit et les méthodes qui se
ressemblent à des méthodes de voyous
contre les gens donc cesser condamnée la
plupart du temps mais en période de
conflits sociaux
j'ai vu le site de l'actuel mouvement
qui veut récupérer il
l'action de besançon nous parle de
guerre sociale
ça peut se comprendre la période de
conflits de classes en période de calme
comme aujourd'hui c'est assez
incompréhensible pour la très grande
majorité de ceux qui s'intéressent à la
mouvance libertaire
ça veut dire qu'on est sur un
groupuscule des gens à la marge de
du mouvement anarchiste alors ça c'est
très difficile pour pour savoir la
pertinence des mouvements qui se
réclament de l'illégalisme d'actions
violentes de ce type là les confluences
son son énorme entre ce qu'on appelle
globalement l'ultra gauche
les différents groupes et puis les
mouvance autonome puisque plus qu
anarchistes ou libertaire c'est plutôt
cette armada qui de puiser les 70 de ses
passages qu'aujourd'hui où étaient
dominantes
il ya des groupes qui visait ben oui
faut y aller quoi il faut réveiller les
gens il faut attaquer tout ce qui ne
trompe il faut attaquer les
manipulateurs moi je sais pas ce qu'a
fait alauzet sont de pâles à son passage
des verts à la république en marche a
peut-être mal mené certains esprits mais
ces actions là ont existé elles sont
extrêmement minoritaires elles sont
variées ans parce que les matches sont
variables pardon parce que les groupes i
will survive très très peu donc il ya
une régénération constante
on n'est pas dans la guerre civile l'un
des brigades rouges ou de guerre sociale
métallisé souvent de 10,80 mais il ya
une persistance me trouve dans la
plupart des états encore aujourd'hui
donc la propagande par le fait ou
l'illégalisme reste une des traces
parfois peu identifiables de la grande
nébuleuse quel mouvement libertaire et
vous me dites la grande majorité des
gens qui se réclament du mouvement
libertaire s'oppose à ce type de
violence oui
la violence est pas opérante elles mêmes
à cauterets reflet du style je pense par
exemple à un assuré qu' siona lis
pourtant donc un des grands
révolutionnaires de dunks aux
anarchistes s'appelle rico malatesta qui
a combattu le fascisme et qui est mort
en résidence surveillée sous mussolini
il disait si on utilise la violence on
utilise les méthodes de l'adversaire on
atteint souvent des gens et des
personnes et non pas le système en place
et donc c'est inopérant et au contraire
ça renforce la peur c'est en france la
crainte ça justifie les lois
réactionnaires et depuis l'action contre
nous et donc pour le mouvement c'est
plutôt
la conteuse âge et donc c'est plutôt à
régner en plus la violence est ce que je
disais tout à l'heure c'est un débat qui
est défoncée d'un mouvement libertaire
les anarchistes sont contre la violence
pour tant que telle la légitime
uniquement dans les cas de violence
défensive en cas d'agression aucune
nécessité par rapport à des autorités
qui sont malveillants donc ce mouvement
là il est forcément marginal n'est pas
forcément négatif yable avec la mouvance
libertaire le terme anarchiste a souvent
été caricaturé c'était pourtant la plus
haute expression dans disaient les
géographes elisée reclus
mais pour la battre pour le combattre
bien souvent mise en avant les actions
ces petits groupes minoritaires en
disant l'anarchie celui qui est poseurs
de bombes en italie le symbole
anarchiste s'appelle un article c'est le
grand chapeau le rend la grande cape et
puis la bombe à la main lac azuei
sardonique et ça ça fait pas du bien un
mouvement qui vise au contraire une
utopie sociale la liberté de chacun puis
des communes libres et autogérée donc
c'est rien à voir avec la philosophie
globale de l'anarchisme comment
expliquer qu'on s'en prenne à un élu de
la république ça il faut le demander
faut donner au groupe qui les jt ça
paraît saugrenue aujourd'hui parce que
si on vise à un débat d'idées on n'a pas
besoin de la violence pour le faire par
contre ça peut mettre l'accent
d'une manière beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus active beaucoup plus opérationnels
5 ou médiatique ce flashmob parce qu'on
va sur d'attirer l'attention là dessus
je suis pas sur quoi que ce soit
pertinent si le sua lozère où les
quelques voix supplémentaires
je pense qu'à ce moment là va lui en
donner quoi et là je sais pas ça peut
être lié à des actions personnelles
d'urbanisme personnel dans la localité
de besançon où environ mais c'est nous
il n'y a pas trop de justification ne
sais pas c'est pas un fasciste n'y a pas
trop virulent c'est un personnage qui
tient une politique et qui est donc la
seule manière respectable ou en tout cas
à combattre si on pense qu'il a la
sucrine bob le moment quoi je pense que
sous son virement de bord doit être pour
quelque chose dans les états ganis
milieu d'un copain électorale pas mal de
mots d'oiseaux qui ont volé sur sur le
monsieur nous est donc ce possible que
s'entraîner un climat de ce type un peu
délétère khl sinon j'ai pas moins de nom
mais on franchit un 15 secondes en grève
au delà des noms d'oiseaux